Jurassic Park we've all seen the film
but very few people have read the book
including me I've not actually read the
book but I have looked at the pictures
because there's something in there that
is just kind of really weird a little
path a beautiful pattern that it's very
little-known so I just wanted to share
it with you so we're going to get to it
just by I've got two got a random piece
of paper it happens to be brown we're
just going to fold this bit of paper in
half so I fold it like this crease it
and you kind of got a seagull there and
it it forms a V of course I mean nothing
surprising so far I'm going to be
consistent here so I'm unfolding that
which is your left over right and I'm
going to do do it again so fold it again
left over right and crease it and if I
sort of pull it apart now okay so we've
got reading left to right can you see
there's a sort of peak then there's a
valley then there's a valley so we'll
call this peak Valley Valley okay or
rare and remember the later if I sort of
close it up a bit it's a it's a saucepan
okay so I fold it over once and I fold
it over twice and I fold over again now
can you predict what the pattern is
going to be of valleys and Peaks now
you'd probably think something as
repetitive as this is going to be some
really obvious pattern and it's either
gonna alternate maybe Valley Pete Valley
peak or you might think I don't know
it's going to create a a little obvious
little zigzaggy kind of pan but it's not
the case if I pull it out it goes peak
peak valley valley peak valley valley so
what's the pattern here and indeed can
you predict what's going to happen when
I fold it for a fourth time so we do one
and two and three and fold it a fourth
time and unfurl it well it's kind of
good to try and predict before you see
it but here we go
and now we've got Pete Pete Valley Pete
Pete Valley Valley Valley
Pete Pete Valley Valley
peak Valley Valley it's kind of if not
random it's certainly not I really
obvious an easy pattern and if I just
start closing this up and you turn these
into right angles you can see that it
what's emerging is something
well something that's clearly not
trivial but it's certainly not clear
what's going on and this is where we
turn to the book okay because you get
yourself your nice cheap copy or brand
new copy of Jurassic Park and you turn
to page whatever it is and you have this
page which says first iteration and
you've got this patent so this is
actually what you get when you fold our
strip of paper four times so if you call
a fold and iteration really you should
be calling this the fourth iteration I
don't know why it's the first iteration
in here but anyway the second question
of course is what is it doing in
Jurassic Park and there's a little
cryptic reference at the bottom of the
page by Ian Malcolm who's the
mathematician who features in this story
at the earliest drawings of the fractal
curve few clues to the underlying
mathematical structure will be seen so
you talk about a fractal so this is
going to turn into a fractal of some
kind can you picture what that fractal
will be I certainly can't not without
having seen it first
if we keep folding our paper which
you're not going to do because there's a
limit to how many times even with a long
strip of baby you can fold it another
fault what's called the second iteration
here produces this pan which is I guess
that what's what's kind of interesting
is without crossing over itself it joins
and forms this little block this little
rectangle another square there this is I
think that the reason why there are
fractals appearing in here is that
there's a sort of theme about the
unpredictability of systems and chaos
and the fact that you know we've set up
Jurassic Park and all these creatures
are going to behave in a certain way and
here's this do monger saying it could
all go horribly wrong because what we
think is predictable could turn out to
be chaotic and so on so that's the
metaphor I think that's being used so if
I keep folding the paper
I get the third iteration it's getting a
bit more involved but it's still hard to
see any pattern emerging from this and
we go quite a lot of pages further
before we get to what's called the
fourth iteration actually there's been a
few more folds here so the the numbers
at the top are kind of going out the
window but now we got this big block
just from folding the paper right over
left and we zip ahead to the fifth
iteration well now you've got these kind
of blocks appearing and they're a bit
like lizards I don't think that's a
deliberate reference into Jurassic Park
or anything but there's something sort
of anonymous animal-like about this
thing and you keep going what's called
the sixth iteration lots way more than
you can fold a bit of paper you get this
rather stunning pattern emerging and in
fact what you'll find is that each of
these that the main shape in the center
has been then rotated and rotated and
typically they're being rotated by 45
degrees and the the dimensions are being
reduced by the square root of two each
time Y folding a piece of paper could
lead to something as stunning as this is
just you know it's mind-blowing we we've
all seen fractals there's lots of
fractals that are famous this one which
is so easy to produce is actually
remarkably little-known despite
featuring in Jurassic Park and we go all
the way to the end infinite number of
folds of paper we get what's called here
the seventh iteration this beautiful
solid block and even more stunning is
the fact you can picture sticking
another of these curves in they would
sort of fit together like a like jigsaw
pieces there's another you see another
dragon curved outline here so you
imagine got a black one a blue one and a
yellow one you could actually stick them
together to make a really cool kitchen
floor tiling be a bit hard to do but to
produce something like this I don't
think anyone would predict that it's
pretty cool hmm I love it and I love the
fact that the whole world knows about
fractals but whenever I show a group who
put group of people the the dragon curve
this I've never seen this before
and who would have thought that you
could get to it so simply
I think he likes it many sides then the
angles become too shallow so the next
one would only have a little bit if I
put in another polygon out here match
that one there I'd end up with only
little Slytherin